I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Howdy, Ange. Bonjour, Jenna. Oh, oh, that's gonna kind of come up later in this episode. There's gonna be some accents later. There are. Oh, it's fun accent day. Oh, no, people are turning us off. No, no, no. They're like, Oh, no, it's accent day. Okay, we won't go crazy. Yeah, this is a fun one, Jenna. Tell them what we're doing today. We are doing product recall season
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你推出了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。嗨，安吉。邦茹，珍娜。哦，哦，这在这一集后面会提到。等下会有一些口音。确实会有。哦，今天是好玩的口音日。哦，不，人们要关掉我们了。不，不，不。他们会想，哦，不，今天是口音日。好吧，我们不会太疯狂的。是的，这一集很有趣，珍娜。告诉大家我们今天要播什么。我们在做产品召回，
three episode 20 written by Justin Spitzer and Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn. Randall, I was so excited when Randall got to direct. We'll get into that. But you know, Randall was our cinematographer. So this was really fun for him and fun for us. Did you know that Randall directed the most episodes of The Office? No, I did not. Crazy, right? I think he did 15. That is so wild. Well, I love that even more. Well, I am ready for a summary, Angela, but I've got a little special something. Sam? It's Angela and Jenna. Here to read the office episode. Do off summary. Where is that from? That is so adorable. Isn't that so cool? It's so cute. That was sent in by Joey Moisica. And he said he recorded all
第三季第二十集，由贾斯汀·斯皮茨和布伦特·福斯特编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。兰德尔，当兰德尔能够执导时，我太兴奋了。我们等下会聊到这个。但你知道的，兰德尔是我们的摄影指导。所以这对他是真的很开心，对我们也很开心。你知道兰德尔执导了《办公室》里最多的剧集吗？不，我不知道。很疯狂，对吧？我想他拍了15集。太离谱了。嗯，我更喜欢这样了。好吧，我已经准备好听总结了，安吉拉，但我带了一点特别的东西。萨姆？是安吉拉和珍娜。来朗读《办公室》剧情的。嘟喔风格总结。那是从哪里来的？太可爱了。是不是超酷？太可爱了。这是乔伊·莫西卡寄来的。他说他录制了
of the parts himself just like Andy. I was gonna ask because there's like a doo-wop part. That's so cool. Thank you, Joey. All right. So here is the summary for product recall. Dunder Mifflin is in crisis mode after paper with an obscene watermark goes into circulation to customers. Michael organizes a press conference and apologizes to a client. When the client demands that Michael be fired, Michael recruits Pam and Dwight to help him make an apology video. The accountants learn how to make customer service calls from Kelly and Creed, who is determined to save his job, pins the blame on an employee at the paper mill. Poor Debbie Brown. Oh, poor Debbie. This was such a fun episode. I loved rewatching it. I had so many fun memories. Same. Oh my gosh,
所有的声部，就像安迪一样。我正要问呢，因为里面有嘟喔风格的部分。太酷了。谢谢你，乔伊。好的。这就是《产品召回》的剧情总结。邓德米夫林陷入了危机模式，因为印有淫秽水印的纸张流向了客户。迈克尔组织了一场新闻发布会，并向一位客户道歉。当客户要求解雇迈克尔时，迈克尔找来帕姆和德怀特帮他制作道歉视频。会计师们向凯利和克里德学习如何接听客服电话，克里德为了保住工作，下定决心将责任推卸给造纸厂的一名员工。可怜的黛比·布朗。哦，可怜的黛比。这一集太有趣了。我很喜欢重温它。我有那么多有趣的回忆。我也是。哦，天哪，
I feel like Steve is in rare form in this episode. I also personally think some of the best quotes of the whole season three are in this episode. Oh yes, it's so many. We'll get to it. And I just want to share one of my favorite quotes of the whole entire series is in this episode. Oh, rare. This is also the episode of animal noises or nonverbal reactions. Yeah. Accents and nonverbals. Someone just hit fast forward. Oh no. Well, fast fact number one, I mentioned that this episode was written by both Justin Spitzer and Brent Forrester. I should probably clarify that there are some writers who work in teams. Yes. Like we've mentioned before, Jean and Lee. They were a writing team. They were hired together as a duo. But Justin and Brent were not a writing team.
我觉得史蒂夫在这集里状态神勇。我个人也觉得整个第三季中一些最棒的台词都在这一集里。哦，是的，有好多。我们等下会聊到。我只想分享整个剧集中我最喜欢的台词之一就在这一集里。哦，太难得了。这也是充满动物叫声或非语言反应的一集。是的。口音和非语言表达。有人刚刚按了快进键。哦，不。好吧，趣事一号，我提到这一集是由贾斯汀·斯皮茨和布伦特·福斯特共同编剧的。我可能应该澄清一下，有些编剧是成组工作的。是的。就像我们之前提到过的，吉恩和李。他们是一个编剧团队。他们作为双人组一起被雇佣的。但贾斯汀和布伦特并不是一个编剧团队。
They were hired separately. So this was interesting that they were co-writing this together. Well, we reached out to both of them to hear what it was like to be paired together on this episode. So they said that Greg just paired them together because he thought it would be kind of fun. And Justin told me that they basically just split it down the middle, that Brent took a pass at Act One, Justin did Act Two, and then they split Act Three. And then they came together one afternoon and they kind of went over it. And since Brent was the senior writer, he kind of took the lead on a kind of a dual rewrite. And then they turned it in and it was kind of, you know, punched up by the staff like every other episode. I could see Greg doing this because he loved pairing together
他们是分别被雇佣的。所以他们共同编写这一集挺有意思的。嗯，我们联系了他们俩，听听他们在这集里被凑成搭档是什么感觉。所以他们说格雷格把他们凑在一起，只是因为他觉得这样会挺有意思的。贾斯汀告诉我，他们基本上就是对半分工，布伦特过了一遍第一幕，贾斯汀做了第二幕，然后他们平分了第三幕。接着他们在某个下午聚到一起，把剧本过了一遍。由于布伦特是资深编剧，所以在某种程度上由他主导了双人重写工作。然后他们交了稿，接着就像其他剧集一样，由编剧团队进行了润色。我能理解格雷格这样做，因为他喜欢把
people to see what would come out of that pairing, whether it was characters or writers. You know, he loved to see what happened. Even our editors sometimes were paired up in different ways. Well, Brent said that it's true that Greg did make it clear that he was the senior writer and that he had final decision on what went into the draft. But he said right from the start, he could see that Justin scenes were just so good that it would be a terrible mistake to put, quote, my grubby fingers on any of it. End quote. So he said that they didn't change any of each other's work. They ended up turning it in just as they had both originally written it. Well, that is so fun. All right, fast fact number two. I asked these guys, what was the inspiration for
不同的人凑在一起，看看这种组合会产生什么效果，不管是角色还是编剧。你知道的，他喜欢看会发生什么。甚至我们的剪辑师有时也会以不同的方式被凑成搭档。嗯，布伦特说，格雷格确实明确表示他是资深编剧，并且对初稿的内容拥有最终决定权，这是真的。但他说从一开始，他就能看出贾斯汀的场景实在写得太好了，如果把“我的脏手”伸进去任何一部分，那将是一个可怕的错误。原话引用。所以他说他们没有修改彼此的任何作品。他们最终交上来的稿子，就跟他们俩最初写的一模一样。嗯，这太有意思了。好吧，趣事二号。我问过这两个人，创作
this episode? Was this based on anything in real life? And Justin told me that he couldn't remember exactly where the idea came from, but he's pretty sure that it just came out of one of those pitch sessions in the room. So it wasn't like one writer had the idea, but it was sort of a collective, one of your group mind things, Ang. Oh, I like group mind. Well, he said he does have a very distinct memory as they were circling closer and closer to something that felt like an episode. Lee Eisenberg suddenly blurted out a product recall. It's a product recall. And after Lee said that, they knew it was going to be like a defective product and a mini scandal. But here's the thing, Ang. Here is why I asked. I did a little Googling. This episode aired in April 2007. And the crazy
这一集的灵感是什么？这取材于现实生活中的什么事吗？贾斯汀告诉我，他记不清这个想法具体是从哪来的了，但他很确定它只是出自房间里的那些头脑风暴会议之一。所以并不是说哪个编剧有这个想法，而是某种集体的结果，安吉，你们的那种集体思维。哦，我喜欢集体思维。嗯，他说他确实有一个非常清晰的记忆，当他们越来越接近一个感觉像是一集的内容时，李·艾森伯格突然脱口而出：产品召回。这是一个产品召回。在李说了这话之后，他们就知道这将是一个有缺陷的产品和一个小型丑闻。但问题是，安吉。这就是我问的原因。我稍微谷歌了一下。这一集在2007年4月播出。而疯狂的
thing is that in August of 2007, there was a massive historic Mattel toy recall. A huge product recall. What did they recall? They recalled 19 million toys. What was it? Some of them were recalled because they had lead paint. Was it a GI Joe? No, I don't know what it was. A bunch of toys that were shown to have lead paint. And the other was because there was a tiny magnet that kept falling off and it posed a choking hazard. But also in 2007, there was a massive crib recall. One million Greco and simplicity cribs were recalled. And I even read an article that called 2007 quote, the year of the recall. Well, that's crazy. I wonder if it was in the zeitgeist. It was in the group mind of the world. And it went into Lee's brain and he shouted it
事情是，在2007年8月，发生了一场大规模、历史性的美泰玩具召回事件。一个巨大的产品召回。他们召回了什么？他们召回了1900万件玩具。是什么玩具？其中一些被召回是因为它们含有铅漆。是特种部队吗？不，我不知道那是什么。一堆被发现含有铅漆的玩具。另一个原因是有一个小磁铁总是掉落，构成了窒息危险。而且在2007年，还发生了一场大规模的婴儿床召回。一百万张格雷科和简易婴儿床被召回。我甚至读到过一篇文章，把2007年称为“召回之年”。好吧，这太疯狂了。我想知道这是否是当时的时代思潮。这是世界集体思维的一部分。它进入了李的大脑，他在
into the writer's room. And it became an episode of the office. Major group mind. That's some global group mind. Okay, lady, I'm going to move us along to fastback number three. I'm calling it location alert. Okay. As part of this episode, Jim and Andy go to a local high school to apologize for the obscene watermark. And Kentipedia let us know because we got some mail. People wanted to know was this the same school where we shot Diwali? People love to know about locations. They love it. This was filmed at a different school than Diwali. This time we filmed at St. John Paul Academy in Burbank. In real life, it is a private Catholic STEM immersion high school. The school colors are white, blue and red and the real students at the school wear uniforms.
编剧室里大声喊了出来。然后它就成了《办公室》的一集。重大的集体思维。这就是某种全球集体思维。好了，女士，我要把我们带到趣事三号。我称它为外景警报。好的。作为这一集的一部分，吉姆和安迪去了一所当地的高中，为那个淫秽的水印道歉。肯蒂百科让我们知道了这件事，因为我们收到了一些邮件。人们想知道，这跟我们拍摄排灯节的是同一所学校吗？人们喜欢了解外景地。他们太喜欢了。这里拍摄的学校和排灯节不是同一所。这一次我们在伯班克的圣约翰保罗学院拍摄。在现实生活中，它是一所私立的天主教STEM沉浸式高中。学校的颜色是白、蓝、红，学校里的真实学生都穿着制服。
For our shoot, we hired background performers to play the students. We did not use the actual students of this school. I feel like that is a thorough answer to this location question. Yeah. You know, I went to a Catholic high school. It was not coed. It was all girls and I wore a uniform and our colors were green and white and gray and navy. I think we're the colors we were allowed to wear and yellow. That's a lot of colors. It's really only five and you're only allowed to wear those colors. Seems like a lot. Let's kill it back. Do you wear? How many colors do you wear? I just grab whatever's, you know, there. Right. So imagine you're getting dressed in the morning and you have to limit it to only these five colors. Well, listen, a friend of mine did that thing.
为了我们的拍摄，我们雇用了群演来扮演学生。我们没有使用这所学校的真实学生。我觉得这是对外景问题的一个详尽的回答。是的。你知道的，我上的是一所天主教高中。那不是男女同校的。那是全女校，我穿制服，我们的颜色是绿、白、灰和海军蓝。我想我们被允许穿的颜色还有黄色。那颜色可真多。其实只有五种，而且你只被允许穿那些颜色。感觉挺多的。让我们收回话题。你穿吗？你穿多少种颜色？我只是随便抓一件，你知道的，手边的。对吧。所以想象一下你早上穿衣时，必须把它限制在这五种颜色之内。好吧，听着，我的一个朋友就做过那件事。
Remember when ladies would get their colors done? Oh, yes. And you find out if you're like a summer or a winter or something. My mom did this. My mom was a summer. Okay. So a friend of mine recently did this. It's sort of what they're still doing this. They're still doing it. It sort of went out of fashion, but whatever. She did it and she found out that she's like shades of blue and coral and white and she just filled her closet with those colors. She's always in those three colors. So what do you know what she is? Is that summer? Coral, blue and white? I don't know what it is. Maybe spring, but listen, it's a commitment to stay in those three colors. I'd have a hard time. Oh my gosh, this is literally what I was saying. I said I could only wear five colors and you're
还记得以前女士们会去测自己的季节色彩吗？哦，是的。然后你发现自己是夏天还是冬天什么的。我妈妈做过这个。我妈妈是个夏天。好吧。所以我的一个朋友最近做了这个。这有点像——他们现在还在做这个。他们还在做。这有点过时了，但随它去吧。她做了测试，然后发现自己适合各种蓝色、珊瑚色和白色，于是她就把衣柜里塞满了这些颜色的衣服。她总是穿着那三种颜色。所以你知道她是什么吗？那是夏天吗？珊瑚色、蓝色和白色？我不知道那是什么。也许是春天，但听着，要坚持只穿那三种颜色需要很大的决心。我会觉得很难。哦，天哪，这简直就是我刚才说的。我说我只能穿五种颜色，而你
like, it's a lot of colors. I don't see what the issue is. And now you're like, I would have a hard time only wearing a few colors. My point was if you're going to have a school that has uniforms, you can't have a lot of options. Why? Because you're- You can't have personal expression within uniform? No. Oh my gosh, you're taking a stand. You clearly not thought about this at all because you are taking multiple positions on this one subject. What's the point of having a uniform if you can have multiple colors and freedom of expression? There's no point. Either have a uniform or don't. All right, well, we had to all wear the same skirt. It was the same. There was no choice or navy pants. Or a yellow shirt or a green shirt or a white shirt. We have to be done talking
却说，颜色真多。我不明白问题出在哪里。现在你却说，只穿几种颜色的衣服我会觉得很难。我的重点是，如果你要办一所规定穿制服的学校，你就不能有太多的选择。为什么？因为你——你不能在制服里展现个性吗？不。哦，天哪，你在表明立场。你显然根本没考虑过这个问题，因为你在这个单一的主题上持有多种立场。既然可以有多种颜色和表达自由，那穿制服还有什么意义？毫无意义。要么穿制服，要么别穿。好吧，好吧，我们都必须穿同一条裙子。都是一样的。没有选择，要么是海军蓝裤子。
about this. On top, you could wear the different colors, but they had to be a collared shirt and you couldn't have any logos. No logos. Not even like, you know, some people, they would try to sneak in like a little polo on their lapel and that would be a no. Well, lock it up uniform. Lock it up. Lady, where are we? Well, we're ready to take a break and then we're going to come back and break down this episode. Well, before we take a break, I want to just share one thing about this episode. Well, I'll just get to it. What is it? I had the hugest zit on my cheek and I remember being really bummed out because I had a nice big storyline and I woke up with an enormous zit on my cheek and they tried to cover it with makeup. Jenna, they didn't splurge for CGI and
要么是黄衬衫、绿衬衫或白衬衫。我们必须结束这个话题了。在上衣方面，你可以穿不同的颜色，但必须是翻领衬衫，而且不能有任何标志。没有标志。甚至不能像，你知道的，有些人会试图在翻领上偷偷塞一个小Polo衫标志，那是不行的。好吧，闭嘴吧，制服。闭嘴吧。女士，我们到哪了？好吧，我们要休息一下，然后回来剖析这一集。好吧，在我们休息之前，我想分享关于这一集的另一件事。好吧，我直说了吧。是什么？我脸颊上长了个超大的青春痘，我记得当时真的很沮丧，因为我有一个不错的重头戏，结果醒来时脸颊上长了个巨大的青春痘，他们试图用妆把它盖住。珍娜，他们没有大笔一挥花钱做CGI把它
scoochy it out. It's in the whole episode. There's so much makeup on it. It's like an orange patch on my cheek. I did not notice it one time. It's on my left cheek. Watching this. Do you have time codes for it? Is that something we can look forward to after the break? Yes. Yes. Well, there you go, guys. If you want to close up. Well, listen, I'm sure you're riveted now. You can't wait to come back. We're going to take a break and come back with this episode. Okay, so we start off this episode with a very funny cold open. I think it is one of the classics of all the cold opens on the whole series. 100%. It is Jim dressed as Dwight, acting like Dwight, and it makes Dwight crazy in some of the best lines right here in this cold open.
修掉。整集都有。上面化了厚厚一层妆。就像我脸颊上的一块橘色补丁。我一次也没注意到。在我的左脸颊上。看这一集的时候。你有它的时间码吗？这是我们休息后可以期待的内容吗？是的。是的。好吧，你们看，大家。如果你想看特写。好吧，听着，我确信你们现在被吸引住了。你们迫不及待想回来了。我们要休息一下，然后带着这一集回来。好吧，所以我们以一个非常搞笑的冷场开场。我认为这是全剧所有冷场中经典中的经典。100%是的。那是吉姆打扮成德怀特，模仿德怀特的行为，这把德怀特气疯了，开场就贡献了一些最棒的台词。
Lady, I remember filming this episode and John Krasinski was so funny. We could not hold it together. Well, we all knew how great he was at impressions and so when he got to actually flex that a little, we were just like, ah, I can't wait to watch. Well, Angela, I think this cold open has two of our most quoted moments for sure. Number one, Bears Beats Battlestar Galactica. I mean, how many t-shirts is that on? It's on everything. And also, identity theft is not a joke, Jim. Millions of families suffer every year. That's right. I see that all the time. Identity theft is not a joke. Don't we sell pencils that say identity theft is not a joke? Don't we have a pencil pack on OfficeLadies.com? Yes. And we have that quote, right?
女士，我记得拍摄这一集时，约翰·卡拉辛斯基太搞笑了。我们根本憋不住笑。好吧，我们都知道他擅长模仿，所以当他真的能在这方面展现一下时，我们都觉得，啊，我等不及要看了。好吧，安吉拉，我觉得这个冷场绝对有两个我们被引用最多的时刻。第一，黑熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加。我是说，那印在多少T恤上？无处不在。还有，身份盗窃不是个玩笑，吉姆。每年有数百万家庭深受其害。没错。我经常看到这个。身份盗窃不是个玩笑。我们难道不卖印有“身份盗窃不是个玩笑”的铅笔吗？我们在OfficeLadies.com上难道没有铅笔套装吗？是的。而且我们有那句台词，对吧？
We have that quote. And we also have Bears Beats Battlestar Galactica. It's just one of my favorite quotes. It is not my favorite quote of the whole episode, though. We'll get to that. But this couplet is so fun and I have seen people at conventions and stuff say this, false black bear, like the whole thing. Oh, yeah. We should play it, Sam. Yeah, let's play it. Play this clip. Question. What kind of bear is best? That's a ridiculous question. False. Black bear. That's debatable. There are basically two schools of thought. Fact. Bears eat beets. Bears beats Battlestar Galactica. Bears do not- What is going on? What are you doing? I love it so much. I want to know what are the two schools
我们有那句台词。我们还有“黑熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加”。这只是我最喜欢的台词之一。不过，这不是我整集最喜欢的台词。我们等下会聊到。但这段对话太有趣了，我看到人们在漫展之类的场合会说这个，虚假，黑熊，就像整段一样。哦，是的。我们应该播一下，萨姆。好的，我们播一下。播放这个片段。问题。什么熊最好？那是个荒谬的问题。虚假。黑熊。这有待商榷。基本上有两个流派。事实。熊吃甜菜。熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加。熊不——这到底是怎么回事？你在干什么？我太喜欢了。我想知道
of thoughts about bears. We never find out. We don't. Listen, we had a fan question from Ashley Trick, Emily Dennis, Faith L, Rianne Holib and Tara LaPorte. Basically, they all said the same version of this. Please, please, please tell us everything about the cold open. It is one of the best sequences on television ever. How long did it take John and Rain to get through it? Here's what I found out, Angela. Okay. Kentipedia thinks we only did about eight takes of this. He said it went a lot faster than we may realize. Well, it was a quick beat. You know, it was a quick scene. And then I asked Justin and he said that he and Brent did not write this cold open. They wrote a cold open where Michael is getting scammed by a telemarketer. But during the rewriting
关于熊的两个流派是什么。我们从来没找到答案。确实没有。听着，我们收到了来自阿什利·特里克、艾米莉·丹尼斯、费丝·L、里安·霍利布和塔拉·拉波特的粉丝提问。基本上，他们问的都是同一个问题的不同版本。求求你，求求你，求求你把关于冷场的一切都告诉我们吧。这是电视史上最棒的桥段之一。约翰和雷恩拍了多久才通过的？这是我发现的，安吉拉。好吧。肯蒂百科认为我们大概只拍了八条就过了。他说这比我们想象的要快得多。好吧，这是一个节奏很快的桥段。你知道的，这是一个快节奏的场景。然后我问了贾斯汀，他说他和布伦特并没有写这个冷场。他们写的是迈克尔被电话推销员诈骗的冷场。但在重写
process, Jean and Lee are the ones who came up with the idea for Jim to come in his Dwight. And they wrote the cold open and it was Mike Shore who pitched the line bears beats Battlestar Galactica. Applause. This is why you need a whole writing team. Look at that. That's how the magic happens. It's a collaboration, people. I have two other observations about this cold open. Not as popular as the obvious ones, bears, beats, Battlestar Galactica, all that. But I have you know, there is a new plant at reception. No, get out of here. What is going on? I am telling you, I don't know when I'll have time to do this, but I am going to screen grab every plant on reception for the whole series. What is it this week? It's a real sad looking plant. It's
过程中，吉恩和李想出了让吉姆打扮成德怀特走进去的点子，他们写了这个冷场，而迈克尔·舒尔提出了“黑熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加”这句台词。掌声。这就是为什么你需要一个完整的编剧团队。看吧。魔法就是这样发生的。这就是合作，伙计们。我对这个冷场还有另外两个观察。没有前面那些明显的热门台词那么受欢迎，比如黑熊、甜菜、太空堡垒卡拉狄加之类的。但我注意到，前台多了一盆新植物。不，别开玩笑了。怎么回事？我跟你说，我不知道什么时候会有时间做这件事，但我打算把整部剧里前台的每一盆植物都截屏下来。这周是什么植物？这是一盆看起来很可怜的植物。上面
only got a few leaves on it. It's in a purple pot with, it looks like some polka dots. And it is through the whole episode. I noticed it's in the cold open, the tag and the whole episode. And in Jim's talking head where he says he created that whole look for $11. We have an old tech alert. Old tech alert. We have the old calculator watch. Oh yeah. Now I know that Dwight always wears one, but just to see Jim actually use it, like you, you hear the beeping as he's adding on it. I just thought it was really fun. How often do you use the calculator on your phone? Surprisingly a lot. Same. Same. I see why they made a calculator watch. Yeah. Because you, you know, I use it. I mean, I remember like, because I'm a hundred years old that, you know, boys would have it at
只有几片叶子。它在一个紫色的花盆里，上面好像有一些波点。而且整集都有它。我注意到它出现在冷场、尾声以及整集中。在吉姆的单人采访中，他说他只花了11美元就打造了那个造型。我们有旧科技警报。旧科技警报。我们有旧计算器手表。哦，对。现在我知道德怀特总是戴着一块，但看到吉姆真的在使用它，就像你——你能听到他在上面做加法时的蜂鸣声。我只是觉得这真的很有趣。你多久使用一次手机上的计算器？出奇地多。我也是。我也是。我明白他们为什么要做计算器手表了。对，因为你，你知道的，我经常用。我的意思是，我记得就像——因为我已经一百岁了——你知道的，男孩子们在
school and they would be told in math class they could not use it. You know, I spent a year where I refused to let myself use a calculator and I had to do all of my math problems by hand. It was just a weird commitment I made to not, you know, I don't know. It was a weird commitment I made I should be able to add 26 and 97 without a calculator. Like just, you know, carry the one or whatever. And how old were you when you made this commitment? I was in my 30s. Really? Yeah. I was really expressing you to say I was 24. No. I just got disappointed in myself for relying on my calculator for simple math problems. So did I know you when you made this commitment? Because I knew you in your 30s. Yeah, I guess you did. I guess I never added anything or subtracted
学校里会有这个，数学课上老师会告诉他们不准用。你知道的，我曾有一年时间拒绝让自己使用计算器，我必须亲手完成所有的数学题。这只是我做出的一种奇怪的承诺，为了不——我不知道。这是一个奇怪的承诺，我觉得我应该不用计算器就能把26和97加起来。就像，你知道的，进位或者别的什么。你做这个承诺的时候多大？我30多岁。真的吗？是的。我对自己过分依赖计算器来做简单的数学题感到很失望。那你做这个承诺的时候我认识你吗？因为我认识你时你已经30多岁了。对，我想你确实认识。我想我从不在你面前做加法或减法。
anything around you. My best friend in her 30s took a year off from calculators and didn't tell me. I do weird stuff like that sometimes. What is that about me? I think you like to make hurdles for yourself. What is this? This is horrible. I just speak to a therapist about this. What am I doing? Why am I making it really harder? You get you get into a real cushy stride. You're like, Hey, these are clipping along. I'm having a great run here. I'm going to give myself a hurdle. Yeah, I don't deserve too easy. I'm going to stop using a calculator. I don't deserve this because she's stride right now. I'm not allowed to use a calculator. Oh, my God. All right. It's okay to use a calculator.
我最好的朋友在30多岁时戒了一年计算器，而且没告诉我。我有时会做那种奇怪的事。我这是怎么了？我觉得你喜欢给自己设障。这是什么？这太可怕了。我得跟治疗师聊聊这个。我在干什么？我为什么要把事情搞得更难？你进入了一个非常安逸的节奏。你会想，嘿，这些事情进展顺利。我这里表现很棒。我要给自己设个障碍。是的，我觉得自己不配这么轻松。我要停止使用计算器。我配不上这个，因为她现在的节奏正好。我不被允许使用计算器。哦，天哪。好吧。使用计算器是没问题的。
Well, I use one now. I mean, that was one of the dumbest things I've ever done. That was one of my one of my dumber goals. I'm sure there's a mathematician out there somewhere that's like really into that, Jenna. That's like, Yeah, way to go. You know what I'll say, at the end of the year, I was no better at adding, subtracting or multiplying than I was when I started. You can't say that. That can't be your button. There was no skill gained. There was no speed. Nothing. I was still, you know, counting on my fingers to carry the numbers. I mean, it was like it was for nothing. You just had a year where you were slightly more irritable. Okay, let's get into this episode. Speaking of people being irritable,
好吧，我现在用了。我的意思是，那是我做过最愚蠢的事情之一。那是我那些比较愚蠢的目标之一。我确信某个地方一定有个数学家会真的很喜欢那个，珍娜。会觉得，耶，干得好。你知道我会说什么吗？到年底的时候，我的加减乘除能力并没有比刚开始时好一点点。你不能这么说。不能把这作为你的结语。没有任何技能的提升。没有任何速度。什么都没有。我依然，你知道的，靠数手指来进位。我的意思是，就好像——这一切都是白费力气。你只是度过了稍微更容易暴躁的一年。好吧，我们切入这一集吧。说到容易暴躁的人，
everyone is on the phone with very upset customers. I want to share with you that there are a lot of delicious deleted scenes and one of them starts off in customer service with this speech and Kelly repeats it over and over and Ryan is like dying inside because he's right behind her and then it cuts to a talking head of Ryan and he's got it fully memorized. But this is what Kelly says right at the top of the episode had it stayed in customer service. This is Kelly. Oh my God, I am so sorry. That is so messed up. Everyone here is so upset. You have no idea and rest assured, your voice has been heard. Okay, I'll be thinking about you all day customer service. This is Kelly. Oh my God, I am so sorry. That is so messed up. Everyone here is so upset. You have no idea
每个人都在电话里应付非常生气的客户。我想告诉你们，这里有很多精彩的删减片段，其中一个片段从客服开始，有这样一段台词：凯利一遍又一遍地重复着，而瑞安内心崩溃，因为他就站在她身后，然后镜头切到瑞安的单人采访，他已经把这段话完全背下来了。但这就是凯利在剧集开头留在客服部时说的话。这是凯利。哦，天哪，我太抱歉了。太糟糕了。这里的每个人都很生怒。你根本不知道，请放心，你的声音已经被听到了。好吧，我一整天都会想着你的，客服。这是凯利。哦，天哪，我太抱歉了。太糟糕了。这里的每个人都很生怒。你根本不知道
and rest assured, your voice has been heard. Okay, I'll be thinking about you all day. Wow, she says it on a loop and Ryan looks like he wants to just explode. Well, Michael has a talking head where he explains what happened, why everyone is so upset, why everyone's on the phone. I guess a disgruntled employee sent out 500 boxes of their standard paper with a pornographic watermark of two cartoon characters engaging in a sex act. Yes, he said it's a beloved duck doing something to a mouse. Yeah, now was he talking about Daffy duck and Mickey Mouse because he says never been a fan, not a fan. Well, I think he would be talking about Donald Duck and Mickey Mouse.
并且请放心，你的声音已经被听到了。好吧，我一整天都会想着你的。哇，她一直在循环播放，瑞安看起来快要原地爆炸了。嗯，迈克尔有一个单人采访，他在里面解释了发生了什么，为什么每个人都这么生气，为什么每个人都在打电话。我猜是一个心怀不满的员工发出了500箱标准纸张，上面带有两个卡通人物进行性行为的色情水印。是的，他说这是一只深受喜爱的鸭子在对一只老鼠做某种行为。是的，他当时说的是达菲鸭还是米老鼠，因为他说从来都不是粉丝，不是粉丝。嗯，我想他说的应该是唐老鸭和米老鼠。
Oh yes, because Daffy is part of the Bugs Bunny. Oh, I can't keep my duck straight. I just like the idea. That is the quote of the day. Oh, I just can't keep my duck straight. There's so many. There's so many. There's so many cartoon ducks who can scrooge McDuck. There's so many ducks. But I love the idea. It just makes me laugh that Michael has never liked Mickey Mouse. I know. Not funny enough for him. I don't know. I guess not edgy enough. Not enough jokes. Well, Michael holds up the piece of paper to the light and shows the watermark. Guess who did a little bit of a deep dive on watermarks? You? Because it wasn't me. I weren't the only people on this podcast. Sam Cody? Anyone? No one?
哦，是的，因为达菲是兔八哥那边的。哦，我分不清这些鸭子。我只喜欢这个想法。这就是今日金句。哦，我就是分不清这些鸭子。有太多了。有太多了。有那么多卡通鸭子，比如史高治·麦克老鸭。有那么多鸭子。但我喜欢这个想法。迈克尔从来不喜欢米老鼠，这让我觉得很好笑。我知道。对他来说不够搞笑。我不知道。我猜是不够前卫。笑话不够多。嗯，迈克尔把那张纸举到光线前，露出了水印。猜猜是谁对水印做了一点深入研究？你？因为那不是我。我才不是这个播客里唯一的人。萨姆·科迪？有人吗？没人吗？
Nope. It was me, folks. It was me. And listen, I don't know if this is going to be interesting. I found it fascinating. I'll do a quick overview. Okay. So we all know what a watermark is, right? A watermark is basically this image that's applied to a piece of paper, right? And you hold it up to the light and that's how you see it. The term watermark comes from the way these designs are created. It's during the wet paper stage of making paper, right? It's almost like a damp. That was really fascinating. A damp water spot. Here's where it gets interesting. Ready? Yes. Did you know that watermarks were first introduced in Fabriano, Italy in 1282? Yes, I did. You did not. Of course, I did not know that. Why did I believe you? I wholeheartedly
没有？是我，各位。是我。听着，我不知道这会不会有趣。我发现这太迷人了。我简单概述一下。好吧。所以我们都知道什么是水印，对吧？水印基本上就是印在纸张上的一种图像，对吧？你把它举到光线前，就能看到它。水印这个术语来源于这些图案的创造方式。它是在造纸的湿纸阶段形成的，对吧？它几乎就像是一个潮湿的。这真的太迷人了。一个潮湿的水印点。接下来有趣的地方来了。准备好了吗？是的。你知道水印最早是在1282年由意大利法布里亚诺引入的吗？是的，我知道。你才不知道。我当然不知道。我为什么会相信你？我全心全意地
believed you. I did my delivery was very good. You're a very good actress. I should have won that Emmy that year. I was really mad you didn't. I cursed on national television. And they're not really sure why exactly watermarks started in Italy then. It could have been to show maybe it was the service of the king or to convey a secret message or prove authenticity of a message, right? But now wait, they were deliberately invented. So one thing I'm curious about is that the watermark was not an accident that happened one day in the wet paper making stage of paper making. And then people were like, oh my gosh, what if we did this on purpose? Someone purposely watermarked.
相信了你。我的表现力非常好。你是个非常优秀的演员。我当年真该拿那个艾美奖的。我在全国电视直播上骂了粗口。他们其实并不十分确定为什么水印恰好在那时起源于意大利。可能是为了显示，也许它是国王的服务，或者是为了传达一个秘密信息，或者证明信息的真实性，对吧？但现在等等，它们是故意被发明的。所以有一件事我很好奇，那就是水印并不是某天在造纸的湿纸阶段偶然发生的意外。然后人们想，哦，天哪，如果我们故意这样做会怎么样？有人故意加了水印。
Well, Jenna, I don't have the fellow's journal from 1282. It might have been a thing where he was like, hey, that's my thumb. Hey, that's cool. We should do that. Oh, I bet the king would like this because then everyone would know it's his paper. I love how this paper maker in Italy in the 1200s journals exactly like you. Exactly. Oh my God, my thumb. Oh, hey, I should tell the king about this. He might like to have his official paper. Oh man, gonna have a glass of wine. Okay. Oh, look at the hummingbirds. XO. XOXO's. Paper maker guy. Smiley face. So Cartier Miliani Fabriano claims to have innovated three techniques, which are still a part of paper making today. But here's the fun part, Jenna, put this on our bucket list. You and I can go and visit
好吧，珍娜，我没有1282年的那个家伙的日记。这可能是一件这样的事，他当时可能在想，嘿，那是我的大拇指。嘿，这挺酷。我们应该这么做。哦，我打赌国王会喜欢这个，因为那样所有人都会知道这是他的纸。我喜欢意大利1200年代这个造纸匠写日记的方式，简直跟你一模一样。完全一样。哦，天哪，我的大拇指。哦，嘿，我应该把这事告诉国王。他可能会想用他的官方纸张。哦，天哪，我要去喝杯葡萄酒。好的。哦，看那些蜂鸟。亲吻。亲吻抱抱。造纸匠大叔。笑脸。所以法布里亚诺的米利安尼造纸厂声称创新了三种技术，这些技术至今仍是造纸的一部分。但有趣的部分来了，珍娜，把这列入我们的心愿清单。你和我可以去参观
the Paper and Watermark Museum of Fabriano in Italy. Oh, that is 100% happening now. How much fun would we have walking through that, getting a tour? How perfect would it be? These two people who are on a show about paper going to one of the oldest paper mills in the world. I can't wait. That is bucket list for sure. Let's get back. Well, let me tell you what Brent told me about this obscene watermark. Oh, yes, let's hear it. Brent, our writer, told me that this watermark for our show was faithfully created by our prop department and that it really did look like a blank sheet of paper. But when you get up close, you can see this little caricature. And he said after the episode, he asked the prop department
意大利法布里亚诺的纸张与水印博物馆。哦，那100%要发生了。我们走过那里，进行一次参观，会有多开心？会有多完美？这两个出演了一部关于纸张的节目的演员去参观世界上最古老的造纸厂之一。我等不及了。这绝对是心愿清单上的事。我们回到正题。嗯，让我告诉你布伦特跟我说了关于这个淫秽水印的什么。哦，是的，让我们听听。我们的编剧布伦特告诉我，我们节目的这个水印是由我们的道具部门忠实制作的，它看起来确实像一张白纸。但当你走近时，你可以看到这个小 caricatura（讽刺画）。他说在这一集之后，他让道具部门
to have one of the sheets of paper and he framed it and it hangs on the wall of his office. And he says, people come in all the time and they say, why do you have a blank piece of paper framed on your wall? And he says, it's a keepsake from the office. Look closely. And then they lean forward and they inevitably say, oh my God. Because, you know, on the show, we put the little black bar up to hide the real obscene part. But on the actual piece of paper, I think it's there. It's all there. Yeah, there you go. And that was that was Phil Shea job that week. That was his job. How was your day? Well, I had to have a duck and a mouse do some stuff. Anyway, how was your day? Exactly. I want to point out something before we get too far. Remember, we said at the very
给他一张纸，他把它装裱起来，挂在他办公室的墙上。他说，人们总是走进来问，为什么你的墙上挂着一张白纸？他说，这是《办公室》的纪念品。仔细看。然后他们前倾身子，不可避免地会说，哦，天哪。因为，你知道的，在节目中，我们加上了黑色小条来遮挡真正的淫秽部分。但在实际的纸张上，我想它在那。全都在那。是的，就是这样。那是菲尔·谢伊那一周的工作。那是他的工作。你今天过得怎么样？嗯，我得让一只鸭子和一只老鼠做点事。不管怎样，你今天过得怎么样？完全如此。我想在扯得太远之前指出一件事。还记得我们说过在这个剧集的
beginning of this episode, everybody's on the phone and they're talking to customers and they're like really trying to do damage control. I wanted to point out that at one minute, 55 seconds, Creed is holding the phone up to his ear, but he isn't saying anything. It's a little bit of foreshadowing, I think, for the fact that Creed knows he's responsible. He's just he's pretending to be on the phone with a customer, I think, but not really. He could also just be Creed being Creed. Yeah, not doing his job again. Exactly. So Michael gets everyone in the conference room, you know, this is like crunch time. And he he says, Creed, you really messed up. Yeah, quality assurance. So I feel like we we officially hear Creed's job title.
最开始，每个人都在打电话，他们在跟客户通话，他们真的在努力进行危机公关。我想指出的是，在1分55秒时，克里德把电话举到耳边，但他什么也没说。这有点像是某种伏笔，我认为，暗示克里德知道自己要负责任。他只是——他假装在跟客户打电话，我觉得，但并不是真的。他可能也只是克里德在做回自己。是的，又没有在好好干活。 exatamente（确实如此）。所以迈克尔把所有人叫进会议室，你知道的，这就像是关键时刻。他说，克里德，你真的搞砸了。是的，质量保证。所以我觉得我们——我们正式听到了克里德的职位头衔。
Quality assurance. Creed says every week he's supposed to stop by the paper mill, give it a check. The one year he blew this off. So good. So he hasn't gone for a whole year. Well, I know I said at the beginning of the podcast that Michael is in rare form in this episode, and he truly is in this conference room scene, but also Creed absolutely crushes it in this episode as well. He does. So we get back into the conference room. Michael has just great stuff. He's, you know, he was speaking in acronyms, crimson, squaw, FNC, not saving any time as everyone points out. And he's really I mean, Michael's really freaking out. He tells everyone this is threat level midnight. Yeah, midnight Oscar. Yeah, threat level midnight. This is such a fun
质量保证。克里德说他每星期都应该顺道去造纸厂检查一下。就那一年他偷懒没去。太棒了。所以他整整一年都没去。嗯，我知道我在播客开头说过迈克尔在这一集里状态神勇，他在这场会议室的戏里确实如此，但克里德在这一集里也绝对表现炸裂。确实。所以我们回到会议室。迈克尔的话太棒了。他在用缩写说话，绯红、斯夸、FNC，就像每个人指出的一样，根本省不了时间。他真的——我的意思是，迈克尔真的吓坏了。他告诉大家这是午夜威胁级别。是的，午夜奥斯卡。是的，午夜威胁级别。这真的是一个很有趣的
call back to the client. Yes. And everybody gives little looks to each other because of it too. Yeah. Well, then Michael says today Kelly will be training everyone on how to do customer relations. And Angela, you have a talking head where you just take a pill and you say you don't have a headache. You're just preparing. Yeah, I loved, I love this back to back talking heads because Mindy is Kelly is like this day it's bananas. And she's so perky and happy. And then it cuts to me just taking an aspirin. Yeah. And my kids were really hung up on this. They really wanted to know was that a real pill? Did I have to take it? They were like, it looks like you take it. You
对客户的回应。是的。每个人也因此互相递眼色。是的。嗯，然后迈克尔说今天凯利将培训所有人如何处理客户关系。安吉拉，你有一个单人采访，你在里面吃了一颗药，然后你说你没有头痛。你只是在做准备。是的，我喜欢——我喜欢这个连着的单人采访，因为明迪饰演的凯利这一天简直太疯狂了。她那么活力四射、兴高采烈。然后镜头就切到我正在吃阿司匹林。是的。我的孩子们对这个真的很执着。他们特别想知道那是真药吗？我必须吃吗？他们觉得，看起来就像你真的吃了。你
swallow water. Oh, Angela, we got so much mail about this. Okay. Carlos L, Teya C, Emily W, Angela B, and Lily N all said, what did you take instead of a real pill? Well, I will tell you, I did a few takes of that talking head and I had to take sugar pills. Wow. So I guess that's a props thing. I've never had to take fake medicine on a show before. So that's weird. Yeah. Phil Shea brought it to me. He said, listen, it's just sugar. It's like a sugar pill. So you'll be totally fine. So I guess I just had a little spike in sugar that day. So also during this conference room scene, Angela, we find out that Jim's client is a high school and they printed their prom invitations on this paper.
咽下了水。哦，安吉拉，我们收到了好多关于这个的邮件。好吧，卡洛斯·L、特娅·C、艾米莉·W、安吉拉·B和莉莉·N都说，你到底吃了什么来代替真药？好吧，我来告诉你，我拍那个单人采访拍了好几条，我吃的是糖丸。哇。所以我想这是道具组的事。我以前从来没在节目中吃过假药。所以这挺奇怪的。是的。菲尔·谢伊拿给我。他说，听着，这只是糖。就像糖丸一样。所以你完全没问题。所以我想那天我的血糖有点飙升。所以在会议室这场戏中，安吉拉，我们发现吉姆的客户是一所高中，他们把毕业舞会请柬印在了这种纸上。
Yeah. So Michael tells Jim he has to physically go to the high school to rectify the situation. He says you have to bring someone. Ryan volunteers, Michael says, no, you have to bring Andy. William Doolittle at your service, AKA, will do. And there we go. We said we were going to bring you accents. We didn't lie. And Jim is like, yeah, I'm definitely going alone. And Michael's like, no, no, I need two men on this. That's what she said. No time, but she did. No time. That is like such fantastic dialogue. Is that your favorite quote? Is that the one? No, still not yet. Still not yet. Well, I remember John could not keep it together in this conference room scene. And anytime John starts to laugh, it is a very bad sign for the rest of us, because
是的。所以迈克尔告诉吉姆，他必须亲自去高中纠正这种情况。他说你必须带一个人。瑞安自告奋勇，迈克尔说，不，你必须带安迪。威廉·杜利特为您服务，也就是“一定能办到”。我们就这样。我们说过我们会给你们带来口音的。我们没有撒谎。而吉姆则是一副，好吧，我绝对要一个人去的表情。然后迈克尔说，不，不，我需要两个男人来处理这个。这就是她说过的话。没时间，但她确实说过。没时间。这简直是太棒的台词了。这是你最喜欢的台词吗？是这句吗？不，还不是。还不是。嗯，我记得约翰在这场会议室的戏里根本憋不住笑。每当约翰开始笑，对我们其余人来说就是一个非常不好的兆头，因为
you just know that we're never going to make it through. But Steve does something in this conference room scene that makes John lose it. I'm going to guess. I have no idea what you're about to say. Okay, I know people can't see me, Jenna. Oh my God, Sam's filming. This is what Steve does at four minutes, two seconds, just to mess with all of us. Yep, there it is. Angela just put her foot up on the table and then leaned into her crotch. Do you know how hard it is to lift your head leg this high when you're short? That table's kind of high. Yeah, Steve took his foot and he put it up on the conference table. And I remember the first take he decided to do that. John lost it. Yeah, because we had no idea. Anytime Steve did that. Steve used to do that to John's desk
你就是知道我们绝对撑不下去了。但史蒂夫在这场会议室的戏里做了一件事，让约翰彻底破功。我来猜一下。我完全不知道你要说什么。好吧，我知道大家看不到我，珍娜。哦，天哪，萨姆在拍。这就是史蒂夫在4分2秒时做的事，纯粹是为了整我们。对，就是这样。安吉拉刚才把一只脚踩在桌子上，然后把身体压向了自己的裆部。你知道当个矮子要把腿抬这么高有多难吗？那张桌子有点高。是的，史蒂夫把他的脚抬起来放到了会议桌上。我记得他决定这么做的那第一条。约翰直接笑崩了。是的，因为我们完全没料到。史蒂夫总是对约翰的办公桌这么做
all the time. Yes, he would. And you know what, Jenna, I remember in this scene when I lost it. I completely lost it when Michael goes, here is your headline. Scranton, area, paper company, Dunder Mifflin apologizes to valued client. Some companies still know how business is done. That's what I'm saying. It's like the greatest hits of Michael in this one conference room scene. In this episode, it's so good. Well, now Michael reveals that he has invited Barbara Allen one of Dunder Mifflin's oldest customers into the office. He's going to offer her a personal apology. He says if the press wants a story, we'll give him a story. Yeah, there's a great deleted scene of Dwight calling CNN. And like no one, no one will take his call. It's like,
。是的，他会。你知道吗，珍娜，我记得我在这场戏里笑场的时候。当迈克尔说：“这就是你的头条：斯克兰顿地区造纸公司邓德米夫林向尊贵客户道歉。有些公司依然懂得生意是怎么做的。”我彻底笑崩了。这就是我想说的。这就像是迈克尔在这一场会议室戏里的精选集锦。这一集里，太棒了。嗯，现在迈克尔透露他邀请了芭芭拉·艾伦——邓德米夫林最老的一位客户——来到办公室。他要向她当面道歉。他说如果媒体想要一个故事，我们就给他们一个故事。是的，有一个很棒的删减片段，讲的是德怀特给CNN打电话。而且像——没有人，没有人接他的电话。这就像是——真的很好笑。哦，天哪，我太喜欢了。我喜欢吉姆说，媒体要求要故事了吗？没有。没有。
it's really funny. Oh my gosh, I love it. I love that Jim is like, did the press ask for a story? Nope. No. No. Michael explains in his talking head, when a company screws up, the best course of action is to hold a press conference. You got to control the spin. You got to control the story. Well, this had me look up crisis management, Angela, because that's a whole thing now. Now, I did a very shallow dive on it. All I found out was that this really became popular in like the 1980s. And this idea of getting ahead of the story is all part of the crisis management public relations handbook. So Michael has it a little bit right here, but he has it wrong in the sense that literally no one knows about this right now. Yeah, if Michael had not made a big to do,
迈克尔在单人采访中解释说，当一家公司搞砸时，最好的应对措施就是开一场新闻发布会。你必须控制舆论。你必须控制故事的走向。嗯，这让我去查了危机管理，安吉拉，因为现在这成了一门学问。好吧，我只是做了一个非常浅显的了解。我发现的全部就是这在20世纪80年代左右真正流行起来。这种抢先掌握故事主动权的想法，全是危机管理公共关系手册的一部分。所以迈克尔在这里有点说对了，但他说错了的地方在于，目前实际上根本没有人知道这件事。是的，如果迈克尔不大张旗鼓的话，
it would have just gone away. But no, he's going to blast it and it's going to blow up in his face. Yeah. So now we see Creed is trying to do his own kind of damage control. I mean, Creed says that this job is the only thing separating him from being a homeless man, because he was a homeless guy. Yeah. I have to say Creed calling up this paper mill and asking who wasn't there last week so that he can then pin it on this employee is kind of genius. Oh, Creed's a survivor. I mean, he's smart. He's actually, he's very smart. He's cunning. Yeah. I was actually impressed. Yeah. I was like, wow. Wowzers. Who thought of that? It's exactly how I got my internship on Conan O'Brien, by the way.
事情本就会自然平息的。但没有，他要大肆宣扬，结果事情会在他脸上炸开。是的。所以现在我们看到克里德在试图进行他自己的危机管理。我的意思是，克里德说这份工作是他和流浪汉之间唯一的区别，因为他曾是个流浪汉。是的。我不得不说，克里德打电话给造纸厂询问上周谁不在，以便把责任推卸给这个员工，这简直是个天才般的举动。哦，克里德是个幸存者。我的意思是，他很聪明。他实际上——他非常聪明。他很狡猾。是的。我其实印象挺深刻的。是的。我当时想，哇。哇塞。谁想出来的？顺便说一句，这正是我当初怎么在柯南·奥布莱恩节目里得到实习机会的。
But how did, wait, what? You know this story. Oh, yeah. You called up and I just kept, I would call and I would get like an answering machine, you know, because I wanted to do an internship at 30 Rock and in New York and you in back in the day before like big internet message boards and things like that, because I'm a hundred, you would have a phone number you would call and it would, I would say hi, it'd be like 30 Rock fellow center. And I'd be like, hi, I would live to apply for an internship. Hold one moment, please. Transfer you to a machine. If you would like to apply for an internship at 30 Rock a fellow center, please leave your name and phone number and someone will call you. I got that message every day for three months. And so one
但怎么，等等，什么？你知道这个故事。哦，对。你打过电话，我一直，我会打过去，然后总是转到语音信箱，你知道的，因为我想在洛克菲勒中心和纽约实习，而在过去，在没有像现在这样大型互联网留言板之类的时候，因为我一百岁了，你会拨打一个电话号码，然后就会，我会说“你好”，它就像是“洛克菲勒中心奖学金中心”。然后我会说：“你好，我很想申请实习。”“请稍等，正在为您转接到语音信箱。如果您想申请洛克菲勒中心奖学金中心的实习，请留下您的姓名和电话号码，我们会有人给您回电。”我连续三个月每天都听到这个留言。所以有一天
day I called up, I got the woman in BC, you know, what 30 Rock fellow center? I said, yes, I was just speaking to a woman about my internship and we got disconnected. She said, oh, Barbara? I said, yes, Barbara. She said, let me transfer you. I said, thank you. Got to Barbara. Barbara was like, hi, Barbara. I was like, Barbara, I was just talking to someone about my internship and got disconnected. And she was like, Oh, were you talking to Nancy? I was like, yes, I was talking to Nancy. Transfer me through to Nancy. Nancy answers, hello. I'm like, hi, I was talking to someone about my internship. And she goes, how did you get my number? Did you tell her? I told her. I said, well, for three months, I called and I got your voicemail and no one called me back.
我打电话过去，接通了BC的一位女士，你知道的，就是洛克菲勒中心奖学金中心？我说，是的，我刚才在和一个女士谈论我的实习，结果我们断线了。她说，哦，芭芭拉？我说，是的，芭芭拉。她说，我帮你转接。我说，谢谢。接到了芭芭拉那里。芭芭拉就像是，嗨，我是芭芭拉。我当时就说，芭芭拉，我刚才在和别人谈论我的实习，结果断线了。然后她就说，哦，你刚才是在和南希谈吗？我当时说，是的，我在和南希谈。把我转给南希。南希接了电话，喂。我说，嗨，我在和别人谈论我的实习。然后她说，你是怎么拿到我的号码的？你告诉她了吗？我告诉她了。我说，好吧，我打了三个月电话，都是你的语音信箱，没有人给我回电。
So today I called and I lied and I said that I was talking to someone and that person transferred me to Barbara. And then I told Barbara a version of that lie and she transferred me to you. And did Nancy say you're hired? Nancy said, can you be here Monday? And I was in Texas. It was a Friday. I was in Archer City, Texas, very rural area, three hours from a big airport. I said, sure thing. What time? She said, I'll see you Monday at nine. I said, great. I got off the phone. I said, mom, dad, I got to go to New York. Lady, that is what it takes. That's what it takes. I think you just like, when you're starting out and especially when you're like the lowest person on the totem pole, you got to have a little hustle. Got to have a little hustle. Guys, you heard it
所以今天我打电话撒谎了，我说我刚才在和一个人谈话，那个人把我转给了芭芭拉。然后我对芭芭拉也说了那个谎言的一个版本，她就把我转给了你。然后南希说你被录用了吗？南希说，你周一能来吗？而我在德克萨斯州。那是星期五。我在德克萨斯州阿彻城，一个非常偏远的地区，距离大机场有三个小时车程。我说，没问题。几点？她说，周一九点见。我说，太好了。我挂了电话。我说，爸爸妈妈，我要去纽约了。天哪，这就叫魄力。这就叫魄力。我觉得你就是，当你刚开始的时候，特别是当你处于社会最底层的时候，你必须得有点闯劲。得有点闯劲。各位，你们从我们
from us. Get that hustle. Okay. So there is a whole bunch of deleted scenes with Kelly and accounting. There's like a whole runner. It's really fun. I mean, at one point, Kelly and Angela get into this huge fight. And Kelly says, you look old enough to be my mother. And Angela then calls her a slut. Oh my gosh. I know. And then they make up, Kelly apologizes. And then she's like, oh my God, we're best friends. And Angela's like, I don't know about that. But there's a whole other journey that Kelly and Angela have that you don't see. Well, now should we go into the car with Andy and Jim driving to the high school? Yes. Is this it, Angela? This is leading up to it. Here are some things we learned on this road trip with Jim and Andy. Number one, we learned that Andy
这儿听到了。拿出那股闯劲。好了。所以凯莉和会计部门还有一大堆被删减的镜头。有一个完整的情节线。真的很有趣。我是说，有一刻，凯莉和安吉拉发生了激烈的争吵。凯莉说，你看上去老得都可以当我妈了。然后安吉拉骂她是荡妇。哦，天哪。我知道。然后他们又和好了，凯莉道歉了。接着她说，哦，天哪，我们是好朋友。安吉拉却说，这我可不知道。不过凯莉和安吉拉还有一段你没看到的完整心路历程。好了，现在我们要不要上安迪和吉姆开往高中的车？好的。就是这个吗，安吉拉？这正是铺垫。以下是我们在这次吉姆和安迪的公路旅行中学到的一些事情。第一点，我们学到安迪
says, beer me when he wants something. Beer is like a verb. Like get me that. Beer me that water. Right? Yes. We also learned that Karen is one of Andy's oldest friends. What? I think that's just because they worked together at Stanford. Yeah. Yeah. And we learned that do not ask Andy to play music. Because he just, he just sings. Like some acapella version of Drift Away. Well, this beer me line is another one of our most quoted. And Jim even says Lord beer me the strength. That's my favorite line. That's yours. Of almost like I think about lines from the whole entire show. And one of my favorite lines from the whole entire series happens at seven minutes, 51 seconds, and it's Lord beer me strength. I love it so much. I love it. I don't know if it's
想要什么东西时就会说“给我拿瓶啤酒”。啤酒就像是一个动词。就像是“给我拿那个”。“给我拿瓶水”。对吧？是的。我们还学到凯伦是安迪的老朋友之一。什么？我觉得那只是因为他们在斯坦福一起工作过。对。对。还有我们学到，千万不要让安迪放音乐。因为他只会，他只会唱歌。比如无伴奏合唱版的《漂流》。好吧，这句“给我拿瓶啤酒”是我们被引用最多的台词之一。而且吉姆甚至还说“主啊，赐予我力量吧”。那是我最喜欢的台词。那是你的。几乎就像我回想起整部剧里的台词。而整个系列中我最喜欢的台词之一出现在第7分51秒，就是“主啊，赐予我力量吧”。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我不知道是不是
because growing up, there's been so many times where I've been like Lord, give me strength. And just to have Lord beer me strength, it just tickles me. I just love it. Well, I reached out to Justin and Brent because I was very curious who wrote this beer me joke. Oh, I would love to know. All right. They told me that their memory is that Ed Helms had a friend in college who used to say beer me. And it was Brent who expanded it and wrote the joke beer me a water. But this was based on a story from Ed Helms. They said he also had this friend that would do the root to do. And confirmed that right. I'd said he had a friend who would do like a gibberish thing to cut people off. Yeah. All right. Well, I texted Ed and Ed is like, I don't know what they're
因为在成长过程中，有很多次我都曾说过“主啊，赐予我力量吧”。而换成“主啊，啤酒赐予我力量吧”，真的让我觉得很好笑。我就是很喜欢。好吧，我联系了贾斯汀和布伦特，因为我很想知道是谁写了这个“啤酒”的笑话。哦，我很想知道。好吧。他们告诉我，他们的记忆是埃德·赫姆斯在大学里有个朋友经常说“给我拿瓶啤酒”。是布伦特将其扩展并写出了“给我拿瓶水”这个笑话。但这确实是基于埃德·赫姆斯的一个故事。他们说他还有一个朋友会发出那种“嘟嘟”的声音。并且证实了这一点，对吧？埃德说他有一个朋友会发出一种胡言乱语的声音来打断别人。对。好吧。我给埃德发了短信，埃德却说，我不知道他们在
talking about. I don't have any memory of a friend. He was like, yeah, they're reading it to do, but I have no memory of a friend saying beer me. I don't know. Oh my gosh. This is like that moment where, you know, something happens and you ask five people what happened and they all have a different story. Yeah. Yeah. Oh man. The one thing we know is that Brent did write the joke beer me a water. So Jim has sort of suffered through this car ride with Andy. Now they're in the high school and they're walking through and Andy's like, oh my God, what's my girlfriend doing here? And Jim's like, oh, is she like the counselor or something? And he's like, no, she works part time at the frozen yogurt place. Yeah. She's that girl standing by her locker. Her locker. Yeah.
说什么。我对什么朋友一点印象都没有。他说，对，他们提到了那个嘟嘟声，但我完全不记得有个朋友说过“给我拿瓶啤酒”。我不知道。哦，天哪。这就像那种时刻，你知道的，某个事情发生了，你问五个人发生了什么，他们每个人都有不同的说法。对。对。哦，天哪。我们唯一知道的是，布伦特确实写了“给我拿瓶水”这个笑话。所以吉姆算是硬着头皮熬过了和安迪的这次车程。现在他们到了高中，正走在里面，安迪突然说，哦，天哪，我女朋友怎么在这儿？吉姆就说，哦，她是这里的辅导员什么的吗？安迪说，不，她在冷冻酸奶店兼职。对。她就是那个站在她储物柜旁边的女孩。储物柜。对。
And Jim's like, oh, Andy. Oh, Lord. So Andy goes up to confront her and she's like, I have to go to Spanish class. Andy's mind is blown. He had no idea that she was a high school student. Andy does let us know that they did not do anything illegal except knock over a few mailboxes with her friends. There's also a deleted scene where Andy talks about how they met in a talking head and he was at like a convenience store and she asked him to buy wine coolers for her and her friends. Oh boy. Well, the actress who played Jamie was Shira Scott Astroff and Lady. She was a contestant on the Bachelor season 16. What? The one with Ben. Bachelor Ben. I don't, I've never watched The Bachelor. Okay. Well, she's a part of Bachelor Nation. So I looked her up on Insta
然后吉姆就说，哦，安迪。哦，天哪。于是安迪走过去质问她，而她却说，我得去上西班牙语课了。安迪惊呆了。他完全不知道她是个高中生。安迪确实向我们透露，他们没有做任何违法的事情，只是和她的朋友们一起推倒了几个邮箱。还有一个被删减的镜头，安迪在一段“假独白”中谈到了他们是如何相识的，当时他在一家便利店，她请求他为她和她的朋友们买葡萄酒冷却饮料。哦，天哪。好吧，饰演杰米的演员是希拉·斯科特·阿斯特罗夫（Shira Scott Astroff），天哪。她曾是《单身汉》第16季的参赛选手。什么？就是本（Ben）那一季。单身汉本。我，我从来没看过《单身汉》。好吧。总之她是“单身汉国度”的一员。所以我去Ins上查了她，
and I slid into her DMs. Oh my gosh. What'd she say? Okay. Well, first of all, Shira and I have a mutual friend in common and it's actor Michael Rosenbaum. So I think it was slightly less creepy when I slid into her DMs because I saw on her Insta that she was friends with Michael. So I was able to lead with that. That's good. Yeah. I'm always trying to find the least creepy way to slide into someone's DM. Hey, what's up? Remember when you were on the office, you want to talk about it? I haven't talked to him a while, but what's up? Okay. Okay. So we emailed her, she emailed back and she told me all about her time on the show because, and whenever there are these scenes that happen on a location and we weren't there, I like to get details. I want to know a
然后私信了她。哦，天哪。她说什么了？好吧。首先，希拉和我有一位共同的朋友，就是演员迈克尔·罗森鲍姆（Michael Rosenbaum）。所以我私信她的时候，感觉没那么毛骨悚然，因为我在她的Ins上看到她和迈克尔是朋友。所以我可以从这个话题切入。那挺好的。对。我总是试图找到最不毛骨悚然的方式去私信别人。嘿，最近怎么样？还记得你演过《办公室》吗？想聊聊吗？我好久没跟他联系了，不过最近怎么样？好吧。好吧。所以我们给她发了邮件，她回了邮件，向我讲述了她在剧组的所有经历因为，每当有这些外景戏而我们又不在现场时，我都喜欢了解细节。我想了解
little bit about it. No, I love it. Every time we reach out to someone in scenes like this, it's always so fun and just kind of fills in the picture for us. All right. So here is what she told me. She said that when she got the audition for this, she had never watched the show before. Really? Yeah. So she said she watched one episode and then went to her audition. It was a cold read, meaning they would not give her the material ahead of time because they didn't want the storyline to leak. Oh, that's so hard. So she had no idea. But then she got the job. And also she told me because she had never really watched the show, she thought that she was going to be playing Michael's girlfriend. So when she got to set, she was expecting to see Steve Carell,
一点这方面的信息。不，我太喜欢了。每次我们联系这种场景中的演员时，总是非常有趣，而且能为我们补全整幅画面。好吧。所以她是这样告诉我的。她说当她得到这个试镜机会时，她以前从来没看过这部剧。真的吗？对。所以她说她看了一集，然后就去参加试镜了。这是一次突击试读，意思就是他们不会提前给她剧本，因为他们不想让剧情泄露。哦，那太难了。所以她完全不知道情况。但后来她得到了这份工作。而且她还告诉我，因为她以前没怎么看过这部剧，她以为自己演的是迈克尔的女朋友。所以当她到达片场时，她本以为会看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，
and that's when she met Ed and John. Now, here is the thing that I found absolutely fascinating. In this episode, when she shot this, she was three months shy from turning 28. Oh my gosh. She was 27 years old. She said she was older than John Krasinski and only five years younger than Ed Helms. Babyface. Oh my goodness. She said she had the absolute best time filming this episode. It is still one of the best experiences she's ever had. And after she filmed it, she went home and watched every single office episode from season one. She totally binged it. And so she was super excited by the time her episode finally aired. She was like a super fan. That is so fun. But she said to this day, people still write her about being on the
结果就在那时她遇到了埃德和约翰。现在，我觉得最绝对迷人的是这个。在这集里，当她拍摄这个时，她距离28岁生日还有三个月。哦，天哪。她当时27岁。她说她比约翰·卡拉辛斯基年纪还大，只比埃德·赫姆斯小五岁。童颜。哦，天哪。她说她拍摄这一集的时光简直是棒极了。这仍然是她经历过的最好的体验之一。在她拍完之后，她回家把第一季开始的每一集《办公室》都看完了。她彻底开启了疯狂追剧模式。所以当她的那一集终于播出时，她超级兴奋。她就像一个超级粉丝。太有趣了。不过她说直到今天，人们仍然会给她写信，谈论她参演这部剧的事。
show. And she's so proud to say that she was part of the office. Well, listen, guys, Shira was so lovely to tell us about her time in the office. She has a new film coming out called Half Brothers. She's also going to be in a pilot on Amazon called On the Spectrum. Her Instagram is at Shira Scott Astroff. But here's the plug I can't wait to give. She is the founder of an animal rescue organization called the Animal Rescue Mission. They rescue abused and neglected dogs and cats in Los Angeles and all over the world. She just rescued like 70 dogs from Death Row in Tijuana and placed them in homes. So she said, if anyone wants to adopt an animal or donate, you can go to the Animal Rescue Mission and check them out. I love that. We have four rescues.
而且她非常骄傲自己曾是《办公室》的一员。好吧，听着，伙计们，希拉太可爱了，跟我们分享了她在《办公室》的时光。她有一部新电影要上映，叫《半个兄弟》（Half Brothers）。她还将出演亚马逊的一部试播集，叫《光谱之上》（On the Spectrum）。她的Ins账号是@ShiraScottAstroff。但这里有个我迫不及待要宣传的亮点。她是一个名为“动物救援使命”（The Animal Rescue Mission）的动物救援组织的创始人。他们在洛杉矶和世界各地救援受虐待和被忽视的狗和猫。她刚刚从蒂华纳的死刑牢笼里救出了大约70只狗，并为它们找到了家。所以她说，如果有人想领养动物或进行捐赠，可以去“动物救援使命”了解一下。我太喜欢了。我们收养了四只救援动物。
I love little rescue animals. That makes me so happy. I know. Should we talk about Dwight preparing for the big press conference back at the office? Oh, yeah. Well, you know, he equates this to beat sales. You got to put the money beats. Those are the attractive beats. You got to put them up front. That's right. He has set up the conference room for a giant press conference all for one man. This is Chad Light from the Scranton Times. He does the lighter side of life. Yeah. And the obits. Right. And there's a great deleted scene with him in Creed where he recognizes Creed. He's like, wait, Creed Bratton from the grassroots. Jenna, he basically calls Creed out as himself. Oh my gosh. And it got deleted again. This origin of Creed keeps getting deleted.
我太喜欢小型救援动物了。这让我太开心了。我知道。我们要不要聊聊德怀特回到办公室为盛大新闻发布会做准备的事情？哦，对。你知道，他把这比作甜菜销售。你得把有吸引力的甜菜摆在前面。那些是有吸引力的甜菜。你必须把它们摆在最显眼的地方。没错。他为了一场盛大的新闻发布会布置了会议室，而这一切都是为了一个人。这就是《斯克兰顿时报》的查德·莱特（Chad Light）。他负责生活轻松的一面。对。还有讣告栏。对。他跟克里德有一段非常棒的被删减镜头，在片中他认出了克里德。他说，等等，来自草根乐队的克里德·布拉顿？珍娜，他基本上当面揭穿了克里德的真实身份。哦，天哪。结果又被删了。克里德的身世之谜总是在被删。
It got deleted out of Booze Cruise. It got deleted out of what was the other episode where we found out that he stole his name from someone in prison, the convict. And now again. So Chad Light goes, Creed Bratton from the grassroots. And Creed's like, yeah. And he goes, I wrote your obituary. And Creed was like, oh, yeah. Creed has this great talking head that he faked his death so he could get like an insurance claim or something. He gets money. And so yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Well, Chad Light was played by Anthony Russell. And I found this in Anthony's bio, which I thought was absolutely so charming. It said, as a child, he played harmonica, ukulele, guitar, trombone, and piano. He worked his way through college singing in a show band. And after he graduated
它从《酒水游轮》里被删了。它从另一集中被删了，就是我们发现他从监狱里某个人那里偷了名字的那集，也就是《罪犯》。现在又被删了。所以查德·莱特说，来自草根乐队的克里德·布拉顿？克里德说，对啊。然后他说，我写过你的讣告。克里德就说，哦，对。克里德有一段很棒的独白，说他伪造了自己的死讯，这样他就能拿到保险赔偿金之类的东西。他能拿到钱。所以，太棒了。太棒了。好吧，查德·莱特由安东尼·拉塞尔（Anthony Russell）饰演。我在安东尼的个人简介里发现了这个，我觉得绝对是太迷人了。上面写着，小时候他会弹口琴、尤克里里、吉他、长号和钢琴。他靠在轻音乐乐队唱歌来完成大学学业。在他从
Montclair State College with a major in trombone and a minor in piano, his band was booked as a Las Vegas lounge act for many major hotels. Well, I played the trombone. What? No, you did not. Oh yeah. Stop it. What are you talking about? Yeah. When we moved to Archer City, it's a very small town. Like in football, it was class 2A, super small town. So to have a marching band, pretty much everyone had to participate. And so all my friends in the town was, you know, I graduated with like 34 people. So my friend Shannon was like, are you going to play in the band? And I was like, I don't know how to play an instrument. She goes, it doesn't really matter. We just need people. And so I was like, well, what do you play? Now, my best friend was six foot
蒙特克莱尔州立大学毕业、主修长号辅修钢琴之后，他的乐队作为拉斯维加斯的休闲酒吧驻唱乐队签约了许多大酒店。好吧，我吹过长号。什么？不，你没有。哦，对。别开玩笑了。你在说什么呢？对。当我们搬到阿彻城时，那是一个非常小的镇。比如在橄榄球方面，那是2A级的，超级小的镇。所以为了组建军乐队，几乎每个人都必须参加。所以镇上的所有朋友，你知道的，和我一起毕业的只有大约34个人。所以我的朋友香农就说，你要去乐队演奏吗？我说，我不会乐器啊。她说，这其实没关系。我们只需要人。于是我说，那你演奏什么？现在，我最好的朋友身高六英尺
three guys. She was like star basketball player. I said, what do you play? She said, I play trombone. I was like, four, 10. I was like, yeah, okay, sounds good. I'll do what you're doing because I wanted to be able to sit next to her. There was only three people in the trombone section, Shannon, Bill Crutcher, and me. And I said, the first day I sat next to Bill, and I said, Bill, what, what are you playing? Because all I could hear was like, and he goes, I just played letter F the whole time. I said, okay. So Shannon was the only one that could really play. But I did learn how to play tequila. What's that? Yeah, I learned how to play that. It's really fun on the trombone because you can, you do this big slide. And then I could never reach the last position,
三英寸，伙计。她就像是个明星篮球员。我说，你演奏什么？她说，我吹长号。我说，我才四尺十寸。我说，好吧，听起来不错。你做什么我就做什么，因为我想坐在她旁边。长号声部只有三个人，香农、比尔·克拉奇（Bill Crutcher）和我。我说，第一天我坐在比尔旁边，我说，比尔，你，你在吹什么？因为我听到的全都是，然后他说，我从头到尾只吹F音。我说，好吧。所以只有香农一个人是真的会吹。但我确实学会了吹《龙舌兰》（Tequila）。那是什么？对，我学会吹那个了。在长号上吹这个真的很有趣，因为你可以，你可以做一个长长的滑音。然后我永远也够不到最后一个把位，
you know, seventh position, because I was too short. My arms didn't extend. Jenna, you wouldn't, you wouldn't use a calculator for the year? I was in a band playing a trombone for a few months of my life. Very poorly, by the way, very poorly playing the trombone. I'm speechless. I don't know. Where are we? Oh God, I don't know if anyone even is listening anymore. Well, listen, I'll tell you where we are. Chad Light has gotten level three security clearance. Don't get excited. It's level three out of 20. And they're getting ready for this big press conference. Meanwhile, Kevin, Oscar, and Angela are busy apologizing to customers, and it is not going well. Well, because Angela refuses to say the words, I'm sorry,
你知道的，第七把位，因为我太矮了。我的手臂不够长。珍娜，你不会连年份都要用计算器算吧？我生命中有几个月是在乐队里吹长号的。顺便说一句，吹得非常烂，长号吹得非常烂。我无言以对。我不知道。我们现在在哪儿？哦天哪，我都不知道是否还有人在线听了。好吧，听着，我来告诉你我们在哪儿。查德·莱特已经获得了三级安全许可。别激动。那是20级里面的第三级。他们正在为这场盛大的新闻发布会做准备。与此同时，凯文、奥斯卡和安吉拉正忙着向客户道歉，而且进展很不顺利。好吧，因为安吉拉拒绝说出“对不起”这三个字，
she will not apologize. She keeps saying things like, our official position is one of apology. Like she's like, we'll not just say we are so sorry. I love it when like Kelly is just patiently trying to coach her to say like just to make conversation. And she's like, where are you from, Ohio? That's nice. She just does not want to be talking to these people. No, no. And also, by the way, in the meantime, Creed has found out that Debbie Brown did not show up to work last week. And he spins a whole tale for Dwight. He says, well, now she told me that she had an emergency dentist appointment. And Dwight gives a look to camera, which I think is a little bit of a callback to his lie to Michael about his dentist appointment. Remember the dentist? Yes. But then
她就是不肯道歉。她一直说一些诸如“我们的官方立场是致以歉意”之类的话。就像她会说，我们不会直接说“我们非常抱歉”。我特别喜欢凯莉只是很有耐心地试图引导她说出口，哪怕只是为了维持对话。然后凯莉说，你是哪儿的人，俄亥俄州？那挺好的。她就是不想跟这些人说话。不，不。而且，顺便说一句，与此同时，克里德发现黛比·布朗上周没有来上班。他给德怀特编造了一个完整的谎言。他说，嗯，现在她告诉我她有一个紧急牙医预约。德怀特对着镜头做了一个表情，我觉得这有点像他之前对迈克尔撒谎说自己有牙医预约的回应。还记得那个牙医吗？是的。但随后
he says, well, then Debbie told the people at her work that she had the stomach flu. So she's clearly just making things up to avoid taking responsibility for this watermark. He's really laying it on thick. Creed is vicious. Yeah. Well, Ms. Allen arrives. And before we get into this really embarrassing press conference, why don't we take a break? Yeah, we need a moment before we get to this. We promise we're going to just talk about the office for the rest of the show. Why would you promise that when we know it's not true? We'll try. We'll try. All right. So we are back. We are laser focused. And we are in a press conference. Oh, it is not going well. No. Michael apologizes to Mrs. Allen and he offers her a giant certificate, which you know he loves.
他说，好吧，然后黛比告诉她工作单位的人说她得了胃流感。所以她显然是在瞎编借口，来逃避为这个水印失误承担责任。他真的是在极力夸大其词。克里德太恶毒了。好吧，艾伦女士到了。在我们进入这个极其尴尬的新闻发布会之前，我们为什么不休息一下呢？对，我们在面对这个之前需要缓一会儿。我们保证接下来剩下的节目里只聊《办公室》。你明知这不是真的，为什么还要承诺这个呢？我们会尽量。我们会尽量。好吧，我们回来了。我们全神贯注。我们正在进行一场新闻发布会。哦，进展很不顺利。不。迈克尔向艾伦女士道歉，并送了她一张巨大的证书，你知道他最喜欢这个了。
Remember in Casino Night, he was like, Toby, are we going to have one of those giant checks? He's so. Yes. I mean, it's a novelty check is what he calls it. It's a novelty check. It's big, huge. It says six free months of paper or 25 reams, whichever comes first. And Mrs. Allen does not accept the apology. Mrs. Allen gives zero Fs, as the kids say. Oh, yeah. She literally says, I do not accept your apology. It's so good. Michael doesn't know what to do with it. And, you know, Chad is back there taking up all the notes on this press conference. He's ready to write his article. Oh, he's his hand is flying across that notepad. He's jotting everything down. So this back and forth between Mrs. Allen and Michael, it just starts to escalate.
还记得在赌场之夜，他就像是，托比，我们会不会有那种巨大的支票？他太。是的。我的意思是，他称之为新奇支票。这是一张新奇支票。又大又巨型。上面写着免费六个月纸张或者25令纸，以先到者为准。而艾伦女士根本不接受道歉。正如孩子们所说，艾伦女士完全不在乎。哦，对。她字面意思地说，我不接受你的道歉。太棒了。迈克尔不知道该拿这怎么办。而且，你知道，查德正坐在后面记下关于这场新闻发布会的所有笔记。他准备写他的文章了。哦，他的手在那个记事本上飞快地写着。他把每件事都记了下来。所以艾伦女士和迈克尔之间的这种针锋相对，开始不断升级。
And then he just asked her to leave and she just storms out and says she's going to call the Better Business Bureau. And Michael's like, oh, yeah, well, I'm going to call the ungrateful biatch hotline. It really, really did not go as planned. I mean, I don't think there's any other way to say it. I don't know. It could have gone worse. I really don't. Well, lady, Mrs. Allen, the woman who played Mrs. Allen so very well was Lisa Dar. And she has done a ton of stuff like Curb Your Enthusiasm. She was a regular on Life As We Know It and Popular. She also had a recurring on Strong Medicine, which is the show that I had a one day guest role on where my brain melted. But I found this very fascinating
然后他直接让她离开，结果她气冲冲地夺门而出，说她要打电话给商业改进局（Better Business Bureau）。迈克尔就说，哦，好吧，那我要打电话给忘恩负义的碧池热线。这真的，真的没有按计划进行。我的意思是，我觉得没有别的说法了。不知道。情况本来可能会更糟。我真的这么觉得。好吧，女士，艾伦女士，那位把艾伦女士演得如此出色的演员是丽莎·达尔（Lisa Dar）。她演过一大堆作品，比如《抑制热情》。她是《我们所知道的生活》（Life As We Know It）和《高中ufg》（Popular）的常规演员。她还经常出演《急诊室的故事》（Strong Medicine），那是我曾客串过一天、结果大脑当机的剧集。但我发现这非常迷人，
because I ended up doing a deep dive on her IMDB page. This is crazy. Are you ready? Yes. She appeared in three episodes of Murder She Wrote. But each episode was in a different season and she played a different character. And then she was in two different seasons playing two different characters of CSI. So she is such a good actress that she can appear multiple times in the same television show playing a different character each time. I felt like that was very telling of her talent. It is. But also, would she change her look? I don't know because I didn't do that deep of a dive. I didn't like YouTube out of her appearances. But I mean, I found that significant. Yeah. And unusual. Yeah. Unless I feel like that happened more back in the day,
因为我最后深入研究了她的IMDB页面。这太疯狂了。你准备好了吗？是的。她出演过三集《谋杀她写》（Murder She Wrote）。但这三集分别在不同的季，而且她演的是不同的角色。然后她还在两个不同的季里出演了两个不同角色的《犯罪现场调查》（CSI）。所以她是一位如此优秀的演员，以至于她可以在同一部电视剧中多次出现，而每次都扮演不同的角色。我觉得这非常能说明她的天赋。确实。但是，她会改变造型吗？我不知道，因为我没有研究得那么深入。我没有去YouTube搜她的所有出场片段。但我的意思是，我发现这很重大。对。而且很不寻常。对。除非我觉得这种事在过去更常见，
like on Bee Witch, weren't there two Darren's and like it was never explained or something? Well, that's like a major character change. This is like a guest role, right? But they hired the same actress in three different guest roles. They loved her. Clearly. Clearly. Well, I loved her. I thought she was great on our show. She was so good and she really just, I mean, pushing Michael over the edge. Oh my gosh. You know, Jen, I did say what could have made this press conference worse. And Dwight, once again, does not help. He says he thought both animals were smiling. There is a fantastic Dwight talking head where he talks about growing up on a farm and he has seen a lot of animal action. And he says really matter of factly,
比如在《家有仙妻》（Bewitched）里，不是有两个达伦吗，而且好像从来没有解释过什么的？好吧，那是一个主要角色的更换。这就像是一个客串角色，对吧？但他们雇用了同一个演员来演三个不同的客串角色。他们太爱她了。显然如此。显然如此。好吧，我很喜欢她。我觉得她在我们剧里演得太棒了。她太优秀了，而且她真的，我是说，把迈克尔逼到了崩溃的边缘。哦，天哪。你知道的，珍娜，我刚才说是什么让这场新闻发布会变得更糟的。而德怀特，再次帮了倒忙。他说他觉得两只动物都在笑。有一段非常精彩的德怀特独白，他谈到自己在农场长大，见过很多动物交配的场面。然后他非常实事求是地说，
whoever drew this got it exactly right. Yeah. He tries to tell Mrs. Allen that the cartoon did seem to depict a consensual sex act because they were smiling. And Dwight would know. Right. Because of his farm life. Right. Well, Michael is really upset. He starts to vent to Pam. I mean, that things got out of control. It's going to be a national story. She's like, Michael, this is the Scranton Times. And he's like, no, we need to do an apology video. Well, then Michael pulls out the video camera and Jenna, the look on your face is Pam. It's so brilliant. It's so brilliant, Jenna. It said so much history. How many videos has Pam had to film of Michael apologizing for things? I will tell you in the deleted scenes,
不管是谁画的这个，绝对画对了。是的。他试图告诉艾伦女士，这幅卡通画似乎确实描绘了一种你情我愿的性行为，因为它们在笑。德怀特当然懂了。对吧？因为他的农场生活。对。好吧，迈克尔真的很心烦。他开始向帕姆宣泄。我的意思是，事情已经失控了。这会成为一则全国新闻。她就说，迈克尔，这是《斯克兰顿时报》。然后他说，不，我们需要拍一段道歉视频。好吧，接着迈克尔拿出了摄像机，珍娜，你作为帕姆的表情。太绝了。太绝了，珍娜。这里面蕴含了太多的历史。帕姆得拍摄多少段迈克尔为各种事情道歉的视频啊？我告诉你，在被删减的镜头里，
there's a runner of videos and they're fantastic. I was going to say that, that we shot a whole bunch of former apology videos and they didn't make it in the episode. I will tell you that shooting the scene with Steve and Rain and then also these old apology videos is some of the most fun I ever had on the show. It was so hard to get through these. It was so difficult. I don't know how you did it. And everything about your expressions, Jenna, are perfection. You don't give away much, but it says so much about what Pam is thinking. I just thought you did a phenomenal job. And I loved these scenes. I love seeing the deleted ones. I want to see more. I could just see a clip show of all these videos that you guys had to do. And I love the small touches. I love the American
有一组视频集锦，它们太棒了。我正想说呢，我们拍了一大堆以前的道歉视频，但它们没能剪进正片里。我告诉你，和史蒂夫、雷恩一起拍这场戏，还有拍这些以前的道歉视频，是我在剧组度过的最有趣的时光之一。要忍住不笑拍完这些简直太难了。太难了。我不知道你们是怎么坚持下来的。关于你的每一个表情，珍娜，简直是完美无瑕。你没有透露太多，但它完美表达了帕姆的想法。我真的觉得你表现得太惊艳了。我太喜欢这些场景了。我喜欢看那些被删掉的镜头。我还想看更多。我真想看一个你们不得不拍的所有这些视频的剪辑秀。而且我喜欢那些小细节。我喜欢他身后的美国
flag behind him, clearly made out of four pieces of paper together. And I loved that from 15 minutes, 55 seconds to 16 minutes, five seconds. Dwight, it's just spraying Michael's hair. 11 seconds of silence, except for while he sprays the hair. I couldn't get through that. I laughed so hard. I broke constantly. It was very, very difficult to get through that. When you think about the real estate of a show, like every little moment counts, you're trying to just jam it with as much as possible. And I loved that our show would take these beats like this. 11 seconds. No one's saying a word, just an aerosol can. Longer than you have to stay on a bull.
国旗，显然是由四张纸拼在一起做成的。我喜欢从15分55秒到16分5秒。德怀特，就在那里给迈克尔喷发胶。11秒的沉默，除了喷发胶的声音之外。我简直没法演完。我笑得太厉害了。我一直在疯狂笑场。要拍完这一段真的、真的很困难。当你考虑到一部剧的镜头空间时，比如每一个小瞬间都很重要，你试图往里面塞尽可能多的东西。我太喜欢我们的剧会采用这种节奏了。11秒。没人说一句话，只有一罐气雾剂。比你在公牛身上能坚持的时间还要长。
That's true. Thank you for bringing my measurement of time back to bull riding. Well, also, I don't know if you noticed in the scene, I kept my gaze on the camera. I never looked up to Steve. And I did this for two reasons. One, because it just felt like I'm in charge of operating the camera. And so I was going to make sure he stayed in frame. And that just seemed like sort of my job. But the other reason was because I could look at the little plastic corner and then I wouldn't have to actually see Steve. And it was easier for me not to laugh. I wondered about that. I was like, Hey, it looks like you're really operating a video camera. But how lucky were you that you didn't have to make eye contact because you would have
确实如此。谢谢你把我的时间单位拉回了骑公牛。好吧，还有，我不知道你有没有注意到在这场戏里，我的视线一直锁定在摄像机上。我从来没有抬头看史蒂夫。我这么做有两个原因。第一，因为这感觉就像我是负责操作摄像机的。所以我得确保他在取景框内。这似乎就是我的工作职责。但另一个原因是因为我可以看着那个小塑料角，这样我就不必真的看到史蒂夫了。这对我忍住不笑更有帮助。我当时还在纳闷呢。我想，嘿，看起来你真的很像在操作摄像机。但你太幸运了，你不用进行眼神交流，否则你会
burst into laughter. Also, when rain drops one of the cue cards and it makes a thud on the ground, that made me laugh. It was like when I was rewatching the scene, just I was breaking constantly. Those poor guys, I mean, they must have been like, Jenna, you need to leave the room. Well, there is a deleted scene of, you know, Michael does the first video and he's not happy with it, right? Well, in the deleted scenes, Jenna, there is his second take at the video. You know, you guys shoot the first one. Yeah. And he doesn't like it. He doesn't like it. And there's a deleted scene. And Jenna made me laugh so hard. Michael goes on to say, I need this job. My mortgage is hundreds of dollars a month. With this job,
笑得前仰后合。还有，当雷恩掉落其中一张提示卡，并在地上发出“咚”的一声时，那把我逗笑了。就像当我重看这场戏时，我一直在不停地笑场。那些可怜的家伙，我的意思是，他们当时肯定在想，珍娜，你需要离开房间。好吧，有一个被删减的镜头，你知道的，迈克尔拍了第一段视频，但他对它不满意，对吧？好吧，在被删减的镜头里，珍娜，那是他拍视频的第二条。你知道的，你们拍了第一条。是的。他不满意。他很不满意。然后有一个被删减的镜头。珍娜把我逗得太厉害了。迈克尔接着说，我需要这份工作。我的房贷每个月好几百美元。有了这份工作，
I can barely cover that. I have a company car, but I still have to pay for the gas. Gas prices are high. And I have no savings whatsoever. Oh, Michael, what's kind of fun for this for those folks who like to catch things on the background? Is that deleted scene dialogue is on the cue card? And their second attempt is right there. You can zoom in and see it. Yeah. A lot of people wrote in to ask, how come what Michael is saying isn't what is printed on the cue cards when they go back and forth? It was just because we cut some stuff out. We trimmed out some stuff. Yeah. He actually said everything that was on the cards. We just had to lose some of it for time. Yeah. Well, over in accounting, we had someone write in, Megan Almond said,
我勉强能付得起。我有一辆公司配车，但我还得自己付油费。油价太高了。而且我一点存款都没有。哦，迈克尔，对于那些喜欢捕捉背景细节的观众来说，有一个挺有趣的事是，被删减镜头的那些台词其实就在提示卡上？他们的第二遍尝试就在那里。你可以放大看清楚。是的。很多人写信来问，为什么迈克尔说的话和他们来回翻看的提示卡上印的内容不一样？那只是因为我们剪掉了一些内容。我们删减了一些片段。是的。他其实把卡片上的所有内容都说出来了，我们只是为了时长不得不删掉了一部分。是的。好吧，在会计部门那边，我们收到了一封观众来信，梅根·阿尔蒙德（Megan Almond）说，
17 minutes, six seconds, Kevin Sass. Yeah. Serious Kevin Sass. Like he's been holding it in for so long. He just couldn't wait. And now he's got something on her. Yeah. Angela is critiquing Kevin's math skills. And he then gives some sass by insulting your customer relations skills. Yeah. And then I call them apes. And then Oscar's like, apologize for that. And I'm like, oh, I'm sorry, you're both morons. And they're like, but you said sorry. It's like I'm sitting with my two junior high brothers. Yeah. That's what they're like. And I want you to know that Brian and Oscar improvised their sort of little high five at the end and that they don't quite get it right. They were so tickled by that moment. Brian kept cracking
17分06秒，凯文开喷了。是的。严肃的凯文开喷了。就像他憋了太久一样。他简直等不及了。现在他抓住了她的把柄。是的。安吉拉正在对凯文的数学技能评头品足。然后他通过侮辱你的客户关系技能来进行回击。是的。然后我叫他们猿人。接着奥斯卡就说，为那句话道歉。然后我说，哦，对不起，你们两个都是白痴。他们就说，但你刚才说对不起啦。这感觉就像我和我两个初中弟弟坐在一起。是的。他们就像那样。而且我想让你们知道，布赖恩和奥斯卡即兴发挥了他们在结尾处的那个击掌，结果他们没击准。他们对那个时刻觉得好笑极了。布赖恩一直在狂笑
up. I love that. They had, they like did a few different tries at it. And it just was like their favorite thing. Okay. Well, I loved that moment. It made me laugh. Me too. Because why couldn't they have just high five? They were kind of doing like a coronavirus high five, where you don't actually touch. Well, and they were trying to do like a fist bump and air and but they're right there. They could have easily touched one another. But that's what it made me think of. I think they love the Jim Pam air high five. This is their dude version. Also, it would have meant that one of them would have had to get up or lean over awkwardly. And so I just, they were like, eh. Oh, okay. Well, I guess it was an optical illusion because it seemed like maybe they could have just
个不停。我太喜欢了。他们当时尝试了好几种不同的拍法。这简直成了他们最喜欢的事。好吧。好吧，我太喜欢那个时刻了。把我逗笑了。我也是。因为他们为什么不能直接击掌呢？他们有点像在做那种新冠时期的击掌，也就是并没有真正的身体接触。嗯，他们本想击拳或者凌空击掌，但他们就挨在一起。他们明明可以轻而易举地碰到对方。但这让我想到了那个。我觉得他们很喜欢吉姆和帕姆的凌空击掌。这是他们的哥们儿版。而且，那意味着他们俩中必须有一个人站起来或者很不自然地探过身去。所以他们就，呃。哦，好吧。好吧，我想那是一种视觉错觉，因为看起来他们好像本可以
made a connection. It would have required one of them getting up. Okay. Well, there you go. Well, maybe we should go back to the high school for a second because we forgot to mention that Andy and Jim do meet with the principal. And it doesn't really go well because Andy is so preoccupied by learning that his girlfriend is at the high school. Yeah, I don't really know. Did they get this account back? We don't know. It just seems like Andy's about to have a breakdown and Jim is just trying to get them out of there. Well, the principal was played by Jim Jansen, who also played Reverend Skinner on Gilmore Girls. A little bit trivia. Oh, that is good trivia. I know. And yeah, we don't really find out how that went. But as they're driving home in the car,
直接击掌的。那需要他们中有一个人站起来。好吧，原来如此。好吧，也许我们应该回到高中再聊一会儿，因为我们忘了提安迪和吉姆确实见到了校长。而且进展并不顺利，因为安迪满脑子都在想着得知自己的女朋友居然是高中生这件事。是的，我其实不知道。他们把这个客户追回来了吗？我们不知道。看起来安迪快要崩溃了，而吉姆只是想把他们弄出那儿。好吧，校长由吉姆·詹森（Jim Jansen）饰演，他还在《吉尔莫女孩》（Gilmore Girls）中饰演了斯金纳牧师。一个小冷知识。哦，那是个很好的冷知识。我知道。而且，是的，我们并不知道事情最后怎么样了。但当他们开车回家时，
Andy is still clearly bummed out and Jim wants to cheer him up. I mean, Jim really, really goes for it here. He just starts going, oh, weem away, oh, weem away, oh, weem away, oh, weem away. Yeah. And Andy's fighting it. He's fighting it. But then he just, he can't resist. He's like, he can't not jump in. Do you remember that time on the show when we all sang that in the bullpen? Was that for an episode? Or were we just doing that one day? I think we just started doing it. Yeah, because it is kind of infectious when someone starts it. Yeah, we were just a little loopy. I think so too. In the jungle, the quiet. Yeah. Oh, one last thing now before we end this episode and get to this
安迪显然还是闷闷不乐，而吉姆想让他高兴起来。我是说，吉姆在这里真的是全力以赴了。他开始唱，哦，维姆阿韦，哦，维姆阿韦，哦，维姆阿韦，哦，维姆阿韦。是的。而安迪还在抗拒。他在抗拒。但接着他，他简直抗拒不了。他就像是，他忍不住也加入了进来。你还记得剧中有一次我们在办公区所有人一起唱那个吗？那是为了拍某一集吗？还是我们那天只是在闹着玩？我觉得我们就是突然唱起来了。对，因为当有人起头时，那种情绪真的很有传染性。对，我们当时有点精神恍惚。我也这么觉得。在丛林里，那首安静的。是的。哦，在结束这一集并进入这个
amazing tag is Creed. Yeah. Creed got this woman fired and he's going around the office collecting money for her. He's going to put it in a card. You know, why do bad things always happen to good people? He asks. And then he tosses the card. He puts the money in his pocket, Creed is diabolical. Yeah. And we also find out that in Pam's opinion, Michael made the best apology video ever. Yeah. That ended with an ultimatum. You have one day. What? Yeah. And where are these videos going, Jenna? Oh, they go nowhere. I'm pretty convinced that Pam never sends them anywhere. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Well, now we have such a fun tag and Rain had so much fun doing this. Yes. Dwight arrives for work the next day dressed as Jim. But it backfires a little bit because everybody just compliments
精彩的片尾彩蛋之前，还有最后一件事，那就是克里德。是的。克里德把这个女人搞丢了工作，现在他正在办公室里为她募捐。他要把钱放进一张卡片里。你知道的，为什么坏事总是降临在好人身上？他问道。然后他把卡片随手一扔。他把钱放进自己口袋里，克里德简直是个恶魔。是的。而且我们还发现，在帕姆看来，迈克尔拍出了史上最棒的道歉视频。是的。以最后通牒结尾。你们有一天时间。什么？是的。珍娜，这些视频最后都去哪儿了？哦，哪儿都没去。我深信帕姆根本就没把它们发给任何人。哦，对。哦，对。好吧，现在我们有一个超级有趣的片尾彩蛋，雷恩在拍这个的时候玩得太开心了。是的。德怀特第二天来上班时打扮成了吉姆的模样。但稍微有点适得其反，因为大家
him on how great he looks and he gets a little frustrated. And he tries to do like the Jim look to camera. Yes. But it's like so awkward. Yes. Well, I want to tell you that this was originally in the script as the alternate ending to the cold open. Dwight had a little talking head where he said to defeat your enemy, you have to become your enemy. And then he showed up to work dressed as Jim. But in the editing process, we split it up, which I think was genius. I love that. I love that we end with it. I remember how much fun Rain had doing this scene. But I also remember him talking with Randall, the director, about how Dwight couldn't be as good of a mimic as Jim. So whereas Jim could come in and just do the spot on impression, they sort of felt like
只是在恭维他看起来有多棒，这让他感到有点沮丧。然后他试图模仿吉姆那种对着镜头看的表情。是的。但看起来太尴尬了。是的。好吧，我想告诉你们的是，这在剧本里原本是开场白（cold open）的替代结尾。德怀特有一段小独白，说要战胜你的敌人，你必须变成你的敌人。然后他打扮成吉姆的模样来上班。但在剪辑过程中，我们把它拆分了，我觉得这简直是天才之举。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢我们以这个结尾了。我还记得雷恩拍这场戏时有多开心。但我也记得他和导演兰德尔（Randall）讨论过，德怀特不可能像吉姆那样擅长模仿。所以如果说吉姆可以走进来做一个精准的模仿，他们觉得
Dwight's version of Jim had to be a little messier. But like, how do you thread that needle, right? Like, how do you do an impression? But it's Dwight doing the impression because Rain could do an amazing impression of Jim Halper. But he had to do it as Dwight. So I remember them playing with that a lot on the set when they were shooting this. Yeah, I feel like those moments would come up for us where it was like, your character steps out of its comfort zone a little bit to do something, but you still have to do it as your character and through that filter. Yeah. But it was fun. It was fun for us to watch those fellas do that. Well, you guys, that was product recall. Thanks for taking that journey with us. We got off topic a few times,
德怀特版的吉姆必须显得更凌乱一些。但是，怎么把握这个分寸呢？比如，你怎么去模仿？但这是德怀特在模仿，因为雷恩本来可以模仿得非常像吉姆·哈珀特。但他必须以德怀特的身份去模仿。所以我记得他们在拍这一段时，在片场反复琢磨了很久。是的，我觉得这种时刻对我们来说时常会出现，就像是：你的角色稍微有点走出舒适区去做某件事，但你仍然必须以你角色的身份并通过那个过滤网去完成。是的。但看着那两个家伙这么演真的很有趣。好吧，各位，这就是《产品召回》。谢谢你们跟我们一起度过这段时光。我们有时扯得有点远，
but you know, there's some real nuggets in this. Lord, beer me strength. Oh, yes. And listen, identity theft is not a joke. Millions of families suffer every year. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. We'll see you next week. Someone beer me a snack. I'm hungry. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earble, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你知道的，这里面真有一些干货。主啊，啤酒赐予我力量吧。哦，是的。还有，听着，身份盗窃可不是个玩笑。每年有数百万家庭深受其害。好了，各位。我们下周见。我们下周见。谁给我拿瓶零食去。我饿了。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。想要免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码office。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。